in Antarctica everyday is an Olympic one
these emperor penguins are near the end
of a two-week fishing marathon bringing
food for their hungry chicks waiting
miles away but a challenger threatens
the entire competition a leopard seal
way to the shoreline it's hungry too
some Emperor's make the leap on shore
before it can reach them the leopard
seal is patient it knows it controls the
playing field superb athletes they sense
the leopard seal and reverse direction
in a split second seeing an opening more
and more penguins stream up and out onto
the ice the momentum seems to turn the
way of the Penguins dozens make the leap
to the safety of land until the leopard
seal changes the rules of the game
the Penguins scrambled to get away out
of the water both the seal and the
Penguins lose their speed and agility
only desperation remains the leopard
seal snares a penguin for the seal
victory seems certain but the game is
not over yet
penguins will go limp rather than
struggle the leopard seal loses its grip
the penguin will make a break for it
this one is gone like a shock it rejoins
us teammates safely waiting at a
distance leopard seal though doesn't
give up it still has good field position
and now element of surprise the leopard
seal won't lose its grip this time takes
its prize into the sea for all but one
these competitors have won the fight to
see another day